there is a weighty agenda for eu leaders
when they gather for the spring summit
in brussels on the 19th and 20th of
march
the first topic will be the energy union
europe needs to secure its energy
supplies and requires affordable energy
as well as climate friendly energy
all of which are equally important
at this summit the president of the
european council donald tusk wants
leaders to focus on energy security and
the internal energy market
one element of the discussion for
example will be transparency in the gas
market
as witnessed in the last few years
overdependence on one gas supplier
weakens the eu and its member states
geopolitically but also economically
eu leaders will also prepare for the
upcoming eastern partnership summit in
riga in may
the eu wants to underline its commitment
to and reinforce its relations with the
six eastern partners ukraine belarus the
republic of moldova armenia azerbaijan
and georgia
on russia and ukraine leaders will
discuss the link between the existing
sanctions and the full implementations
of all the points in the minsk
agreements brokered by president
hollande and chancellor merkel
on the second day of the summit the
situation in libya will be addressed
the critical situation is already a
tragedy for the libyan population and
poses serious challenges in terms of
migration and terrorism for europe
as regards the transatlantic trade and
investment partnership the eu-us trade
talks eu leaders will take stock of the
progress so far
they will reiterate their december 2014
summit pledge to see the deal concluded
by the end of 2015.
the european council will then discuss
the european economy and reconfirm the
three main pillars of its strategy
investments reforms and sound public
finances